foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work they love
and create amazing relationships
I'm George Campbell Join This Hour by my
good friend and my arch nemesis Dr John
deloney best-selling author and host of
the Dr John deloney show you can listen
to that wherever you listen to podcasts
and on YouTube as well if you want to
see John's face it's a glorious face and
hey we have a a wild uh studio audience
today so it's good to see everybody yeah
the camera can't even pan to capture all
the people it's just too many it's it's
pretty well it's good I don't know I
thought you guys had a job or something
but if you want to visit us we have room
that's all we're saying it's this is the
dead time after you know people's winter
break they're back in school they're not
so good about about you George
um you're able to look at a situation
like this and not immediately get
existentially down on yourself well
there's millions of people listening not
everyone's going to tune in to a radio
show live from a lobby but I want to let
you know we're here that's very true and
we appreciate you all tuning in the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life your money your
relationships your mental health you
name it Melissa kicks us off and test
Colusa Alabama Melissa welcome to the
show
hi hey hey how are you glad to be here
we are so glad to have you what's going
on
well we uh I just found out that my
husband's been given my brother-in-law a
large amount of money
um I knew we were giving him some but I
just found out that it's a lot more than
I thought and he did kind of come clean
about what he thought he'd given him
he's not been keeping track of it but
it's been in the thousands and he's not
you know been holding him accountable or
anything just giving him the cash so
what did you guys agree on originally
when you talked about this and you said
hey I'm cool with this it's going to be
how much a month
we're getting really agree he just um he
would you know I knew that my
brother-in-law needed someone he had
given him some you know and I I don't
know that we didn't really like sit down
and say okay this is what we need to
give him I just knew that he had given
him some we all have the same account he
and I have the same accounts we all have
you know the login so I could have
logged in and kind of found this out
early I just don't typically check
behind him like that because I've never
had the need to are you frustrated at
yourself are you frustrated at him or
both uh
I just don't he he said from here
forward he would he will tell me
everything that he gives him you know
we'll agree to it and all that kind of
stuff and I think he I think I don't
think that's I think that's gonna that's
a recipe for disaster for you too
oh really yes I think you need to set up
a set amount on this end of it and a set
of values for which we will put money
towards and those which we will not
because him just telling you what he's
spending you are going to slowly the
resentment is just going to start moving
up like a thermometer until it finally
blows and he's gonna look at you and say
what I told you
and you will have felt like you uh were
setting money on fire in the living room
and so I think you guys need to have the
hard conversation you and your husband
um
that he didn't lie to you but you don't
feel like he told you the whole like
this is out of character for him to give
somebody five or ten thousand dollars
and not mention the number right
so it's a little bit shady and if if you
called him on it he would say I told you
I was giving him money and so here you
are I think we I think you Turn All the
Lights On you turn the music off stop
the party and say
you gave ten thousand dollars this is
out of character you knew deep down that
I would have had a problem with how much
you were giving him and if you say I
wouldn't keep in track come on man and
so no we did have the conversation we
did go through all that okay and he did
and and basically what he said was I was
wrong I should never be good for that
good for him you know yeah and and I you
know and I said this is so out of
character for you you know because it
really is or so I thought we've been
married 20 nearly 25 years and um and I
said it's just you know he's always had
a good mindset about money and
accountability and you know he agreed
that we we have just one daughter and
she's grown you know in her 20s and and
I said you would never just give her
thousands and not make her accountable
why is it okay to give your brother that
and he just feels really sorry for him
and I do too you know he's yeah and um
and so I just I wanna I don't really
know like this you know point forward
like I I would say we hired like a third
party no no no no no this is about y'all
being grown-ups and I would I it's I'm
gonna put words in your mouth so feel
free to not use these exact words okay
but I would say something along the
lines of hey I've had a couple of days
to think on our conversation I'm really
grateful that you took ownership of
what you did that means a lot to me and
I'm not in a place yet where I feel safe
and make it all about you it's not about
him this is about you I don't feel safe
um just saying we're just gonna do this
however whenever
and so
let's come up with a number that we're
going to say this is what we're gonna
give him
and let's talk about when we're gonna
give it to them how we're gonna give it
to them why we're gonna give it to them
and the conversation husband you need to
have with your brother about this is it
or we will we will come back to the well
but he's gonna have to make a
presentation to defend whatever makes
you feel safe and and comfortable but
let's put some boundaries on this thing
let's put some um uh let's put some very
clear parameters on this before it gets
going any further Melissa there's three
steps number one is what John said it's
between you two and communication and
what happened here was you had a thought
that you thought was communication but
there was no expectations said out loud
and so we need to do that number one
number two he needs to have the
conversation with the brother setting
the boundaries of what this looks like
very clearly what this looks like when
it's going to end how much all the
things John said and number three you
guys need to get on a written plan a
budget that both of you have agreement
on that both of you look at every month
it's not he does it
I look at it once a month to see what
happened in the past that is a recipe
for disaster and so I'm going to gift
you every dollar premium for one year to
make this really easy for you all to do
a budget every single month and stick to
it and then it becomes hey guess what
that giving to the brother it was in the
budget so there's no money fights about
this anymore
it's that simple
that sounds good is that cool and before
we let you go Melissa
are you an Alabama fan
I was hoping you were going to stand
strong but I should have known Melissa I
shouldn't know we love you anyways
Melissa I love you anyways wow well this
is a it's this is a very common
conundrum where money and relationships
get involved and it usually stems around
communication well and also I think it's
she called something out that's really
important for everybody listening
um I can
the roles we play in our life are all
almost always environmentally specific
what I mean by that I had a reputation
in my professional life of being really
Frugal like obnoxiously Frugal always
coming in on budget or under budget
in my private life my wife is like wow
you were a co-host of Ramsay show and
this is how you do this so so he was a
financially secure guy he always was
really diligent and intentional but when
it came to the love between him and his
brother it kind of went crazy and became
somebody he didn't want to be so when
you catch somebody in a different role
let's bring them back to home base and
say this is who we're gonna be moving
forward and this is my expectation for
you and I love that you got to write it
down you got to be clear and then you
gotta move on that's wisdom hey more of
your calls coming up triple eight eight
two five five two two five this is the
Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined this hour by Dr
John deloney open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in we'll talk life money mental
health relationships whatever is on your
mind Amber joins us up next in Seattle
Amber welcome to the show
hello thanks for having me absolutely
what's going on
um okay so me and my husband we uh
grossed last year uh 84 672 dollars
um we've been debt free since 2017
um so it's pretty good but we kind of
got sidetracked a little bit as we're in
2023 and we're still working the baby
steps
um so my question today is we both have
a whole life insurance policy
um we pay 7 548 a year for this policy
ouch
um yeah so
um at best
um my husband would get I don't have my
numbers in front of me but he would get
six hundred thousand no sorry at worst
um because there's the paid up editions
um I'm sure you guys know about those
but um with that I thought worse he
would get six hundred thousand dollars
ask us to get 1.269 million
um and that's what in our policy we
would get the um the paid up the dishes
or that cash value
uh well that editions would be added in
so that's part of our policy
um so if you canceled it today what
would you get
um if we got cash value today at the uh
thirty two thousand dollars okay and
what's your question today
um so that's the cash value and I mean
his would be so we're right at that six
year mark so his would be the death
benefit would be 219 000. so my question
is are my guys kind of telling me to
cancel that as soon as possible you've
got 32 000 to finish up our baby steps
which is
5451 to finish that up and then we'll
have a fully loaded emergency funds so
that's kind of what I'm leaning towards
but you know having
primary assurances always nice we also
have a term life insurance policy both
of us have 400 000 each for that I've
talked to the rep and he kind of
recommends getting a little bit higher
and canceling that 400 000 one and and
then doing 500 000 for me and 750 000
for my husband is that closer to 10 10
times 12 times your incomes yeah okay
yeah I think that's the that's the move
and make sure that you have those term
policies in place before you cancel uh
and I think you're exactly right what
you're feeling right now is the emotion
of sunk cost fallacy where you went yeah
we fell for this thing we've been paying
so much into it and we could have had
1.2 but now we're gonna have thirty
thousand dollars and this sucks and uh
this is what we call a stupid tax where
you go that was dumb right shouldn't
have fell for it and I'm gonna get term
life it's going to be a fraction of the
cost what are you paying for term life
uh it's like 530 dollars a month right
now or a year sorry a year that sounds
more like it and so right now you're
paying 625 a month for those Whole Life
policies and you could be paying 500
bucks a year for the same amount of
coverage
yeah and so with the difference you can
use that towards the baby steps the
amount that you're saving every month
you can go invest that you can use it to
live your best life and uh not fall for
these stupid whole life scams again
yeah I guess my next question would be
um once we have gotten that third baby
step
um we we rent right now for about twelve
hundred dollars a month which is pretty
much unheard of in in Washington that's
a good one it's a four bedroom yeah
like some yeah oh my God so my husband's
a teacher and he kind of gets them
benefits through working at the school
system but so I mean it's a really great
opportunity as far as our rental is
concerned but um we want to eventually
buy so because we don't have that
mortgage
um where do we like do we keep putting
money into like the baby steps the 15
and slowly building up a down payment or
do we just shove a bunch of money
towards a down payment so we have a baby
step that's hidden in there called baby
step 3B where you can save aggressively
for the down payment before you start
investing if you'd like and so if you
can do that in under two years and have
that down payment in place that's great
some people go you know what I'd rather
get started investing I'm going to
invest up to the match and whatever's
beyond that we can put towards the down
payment some people go I'm going to do
all 15 whatever's left we're gonna put
towards that down payment obviously
that's going to slow you down a little
bit on the down payment side but it's
all about your goals and how quickly you
want to get into a home and if you're
happy with your rent right now and you'd
rather get to investing you can split
the difference and uh amber
um while you and George were talking I
ran a few numbers here
um love when John does math it's so yeah
the world the world needs still only
need to do more math
um so let's say you had zero dollars in
Investments and did you say it was about
7 500 a Year y'all were putting in
is that each or just or individually
totally okay
so if I divide that out by 12 at 629
bucks a month okay that you're put
you're putting in right
yep at uh 10 annual return which is a
little less than what the stock market
has been over the last 50 years you
would end up with 4.8 million dollars
I know I'm like kicking myself because
pictures has made a big difference
that's like 1.2 million dollars right
but you see how it just feels like okay
like Max we can get 1.2 and you can see
why Dave is so adamant and has been for
years get out of those products because
here's the part that's infuriating
somebody's making 4.8 it's just not you
right right you're gonna make 800 and
you're gonna hand four million of your
dollars to somebody else and they're
gonna say thank you I will apply this to
my third yacht appreciate you yeah right
so good for you good for you
way to go Amber we're cheering you on on
the journey appreciate the call let's
move on to Jackson in Tampa Florida
Jackson welcome to the show sorry Miss
Jackson I apologize what's up I was
expecting it as soon as I heard John was
on the call and I knew I knew it was
coming I am fine I almost wanted to give
you a different name just so John
wouldn't have that opportunity hey man
my name rhymes with the lunch meat dude
we we're all the same team here what's
up man yeah all right hey yeah I just I
was wondering uh I know Dave recommends
mutual funds over like the low-cost
index funds and for my limited knowledge
I was thinking that the index funds
typically outperform when you take into
account the fees so I was wondering kind
of what the math is behind the
recommendation
it's a great question and it's one we
get a lot around here and we actually
just recently had a meeting where we
actually walked through the numbers on
this and it was showing us the charts
from the last 30 years and truthfully
let me just say this Jackson up front
you can be a multi-millionaire either
way and so this is a very nuanced
conversation we're not talking about
crypto versus index funds or single
stocks versus mutual funds we're talking
about something that is very similar
what do you have a group of stocks all
together
and the index is just saying it's going
to be passively managed which is why you
have a lower cost on your expense ratios
that's what you're talking about correct
yeah yes sir yep and so with the
actively managed mutual funds there can
be an upfront fee there can be a higher
expense ratio and the idea here is there
is very smart people actively managing
those portfolios and choosing those
stocks in order to beat the index does
it beat them every time every year no
but can it over time and can you choose
the right ones it's definitely possible
and you can pull the numbers you know a
lot of different ways but the I thought
I thought that was it was it Vanguard
somebody just came out with a study and
again I don't want to misquote somebody
but it was a index fun company that came
out and said hey they they beat us by
three percent if they were honest about
it they had a study that said if you
work with an advisor that you will have
an on average I think about a three
percent higher return which I I hold in
high esteem I hold them in high esteem
from the courage to come out and not
bury that right they said hey yeah we
have a great product here but if you get
with a good a good team they they can
out they can outperform us
isn't that almost the opposite of the
like what's been kind of in the past
as far as what random walk down Wall
Street like if you read the book random
walk down Wall Street or something like
that
yeah I mean if you look at you know
there's the Bogle heads out there or
there's the people who follow kind of
Warren Buffett's train of thought and if
you just put your money into a Vanguard
index fund and do that consistently then
yes you will become a millionaire and
you'll be just fine for the people that
we're talking to
on average if they do it themselves
they're going to do something stupid
along the way they're going to pull
their money out early they're not
thinking about tax advantages they're
not thinking about Estate Planning and
so that's why we recommend working with
an advisor when you have that level of
wealth there's just more to manage and
let me tell you this Jax like everybody
thinks the rules don't apply to them I'm
a pretty smart guy I've accomplished
some cool stuff in my life and once a
quarter my smartvester Pro will call me
and say do not open your mail
you don't need to see it because then
I'm going to start hassling I'm going to
want to move this and get out of this
and I know not to and so hard I can't
help it so I need a coach man it's
accountable to have somebody in my
corner absolutely if you're just using a
smart investor Pro to just choose a fund
then you're missing the point it's way
bigger than that and there's nothing
wrong with index funds we're big fans of
those uh we just find that you can beat
them over the long run so thanks for the
call man this is the Ramsay show
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell co-piloted with my friend Dr
John deloney this hour co-piloted with
that's a word
I think wow ah listen this is why you
have two phds and I'm just a guy all
right nope I'm happy to be co-piloted
with you well speaking of Education John
BuzzFeed is where I get all of my
information
and this article came across the old
desk here and I thought you would like
it as I know you you don't look at a lot
of BuzzFeed I'm a huge buds BuzzFeed fan
well here's the headline
um with what money Millennials and gen Z
are sharing the money tips they think
are super outdated considering the fact
we're all super broke very relatable
very empathetic on buzzfeed's part I I
see why this is so popular so I want to
read a few and get your your commentary
if you will here's one someone said
anytime someone tells me to save money I
automatically roll my eyes I would love
to be able to have a savings of some
kind but with inflation twerking all
over the place it's impossible
especially when my son keeps growing out
of his clothes every other month even
thrift store prices are getting
ridiculous
what do you think John
um
I think this is a case of
the great brene Brown says whatever you
go looking for in the world you're sure
to find
and so sometimes instead of staring at
the reality the totality of our reality
and that I realize that rhymes and I
should probably be an artist a poet
um if you got to look at all of your
reality including where you live what
you're doing for a living
what is reality for you right now I wish
I had all this extra time with my kids
but right now we're broke and we I I
can't afford that time right now because
I gotta go to another job like in this
hard heartbreaking conversations people
have in half
then somebody says hey you need to pay
your bills you need to work to save some
money it's easy to laser in on that one
little word save and blow up all of the
truth and wisdom and that sentiment
because that particular thing doesn't
apply to you in this particular hard
season that you're in
um it's it's an easy way to avoid
reality and so
um
everyone should be saving money and not
everybody can right now both of those
things are true and so if that's not you
right now don't roll your eyes exhale
and say I'm going to work really hard
and get there right that's good and
that's why our baby steps are one at a
time focused intensity yeah so we only
want you to save a thousand dollars when
you get started no more because it is
overwhelming and you have to sell some
stuff it's gonna be super uncomfortable
not fun anybody who goes into this thing
that's going to be a blast is Miss the
point completely it's not going to be
all right here's another one
someone said sell your car and get a
cheaper older one this is terrible
advice for a lot repairs and unreliable
Transportation are a financial Nightmare
and again that somebody saw the word
cheaper older one the words cheaper
older one and they immediately went to
it falls apart and you can't have a
cheaper not in their mind they're
picturing like a 1970s Oldsmobile right
or they're picturing a a something
that's not even real they're not
picturing anything they're just trying
to pull apart an argument right what
this is saying is uh let me say this in
a different way you don't deserve
there's no Cosmic right to a new car
there's no Cosmic right to the car of
your dreams that's why they call it of
your dreams because it's not real it's
not a real thing
um
when new cars are an all-time high and
so what they're saying is hey instead of
driving something older that's going to
catch on fire on the interstate because
someone drove it before me I'm going to
drive a brand new 45
000 car under the guise of safety and
reliability right instead of I want it
because it makes me feel good and I want
to look good that's right and this
argument is particularly challenging
when someone brings it to you or me
because both of us are not car people
we've always driven used cars we always
drive old used cars I bought my first
new car I think ever the other day wow
at what age at 45 and so there we go and
I made it right and so all I have to say
is like man you can have a great
wonderful wonderful great life with a
old cheaper used car absolutely and uh
there's no such thing as well it's gonna
have way more repairs and it's
unreliable do an inspection get a Honda
or your favorite the Toyotas and what
did you used to call them Toyota I do it
like Yoda from Star Wars and James gets
mad at me well since sorry it's my
Arabic accent coming out James sorry all
right here's one for you John
um I'm so sick of hearing that I should
buy a house right now just to have one
maybe that was a great idea a few years
ago but houses in my area are currently
selling for at least double maybe even
triple what they were three years ago
also along with home ownership comes a
regular and irregular costs that can
range from basic utilities to needing a
whole new roof it's just not realistic
or even logical this one I actually
agree with well let me that everyone
needs a house and you should be in a
house and why aren't you in a house and
renting's a sin it I but I don't like
the first sentence I've never heard
somebody say you need a house just to
have one nobody says that that is
twisting an argument to make it sound a
little bit off-kilter a little bit dumb
so that then you can pull it apart just
be honest a lot of people particularly
our parents age say if if you rent
something you're just throwing your
money away I've heard that multiple
times from people a generation or two
well-meaning people exactly and in their
world that was accurate in our world
it's not renting is a wise thing I've
I've rented at every stage of my life
whenever time me and my wife move and me
and my kids move we rent until we get
set right so just like you said you're
exactly right it's not logical or
realistic for a lot of people right now
yeah cool make peace with it okay now
should it be a long-term goal I think
it's a great goal to have long term does
it need to happen tomorrow no there's
great flexibility there's great wisdom
you're offloading the risk onto someone
else and you're paying for the privilege
of all of that that's right that's a
good one all right have three to six
months worth of expenses in your account
in case of emergency that's great but
when I can barely make all my bills each
month what money am I supposed to be
saving
so they agree with the advice that you
should have a savings account an
emergency fund but they're angry uh that
people are recommending this as if it's
some something they can just go do and
the conversations I've had around this
around this very this very issue over my
career most of the people in my career
that I've hired
um
were it was their first or second job
they were they were new to the job world
and so there was an expectation that now
that I've got this degree and this
position at this University this this
degree with this this many years of
experience the world's just gonna hand
me this much money
and unfortunately often this is what
this job paid
and so it was less about where's all
this money I'm supposed to be saving and
more about sitting back and going okay I
wanted to do this career and I wanted to
make this much money right now the world
isn't paying this much money for this
career I need to have a hard
conversation with am I going to change
my am I going to reduce how much I spend
am I going to get a new job am I going
to move right all all
incredibly hard conversations but the
idea that I went and did a thing I got
this education I got this training and I
want to live here and I want to work
there and I want to make this much money
those three things are not automatic and
they often don't work together and man
we have a culture that's having a hard
time reconciling those three things well
they were sold a lot of lies and now
they're met with a harsh reality right
and so the gap between those two just
keeps I watched Friends I want to work
in a retail store have a 4 000 square
foot apartment in downtown where it's
just not I've been watching Seinfeld
Kramer is unemployed the entire series a
guy lives in a New York apartment across
the hall from a comedian right gosh what
a sitcom all right last one for you John
this is a very close to home someone
said the majority of Dave Ramsey's
Financial advice especially if you're
working on paying off debt the only time
you should see the inside of a
restaurant is if you're working there
with the student loan crisis as it is my
20 meal at a restaurant once a month
isn't going to make a difference in
whether I pay off 50 Grand in student
loans I've paid my loans every single
month and right now I owe more than I
originally took out 10 years ago all due
to student loan interest I'm done with
the shaming and being told I don't
deserve a life or the ability to be out
in public
that's right that's that's always been
Dave's advice you're not allowed to be
out in public John yeah Dave's big on
shaming people and telling them they
don't deserve a life I think he's in
Cabo right now if I'm not mistaken I
think so living here last we checked I I
I mean again this is someone who's
struggling and is upset and I'm not I'm
not going to be mad
um well because to them all they have in
life John is this takeout meal that's it
that's all they're left with but it's a
symbol it's saying what are you willing
to sacrifice right now that will add up
to where you have 500 bucks that month
and then 600 bucks the next month to
where you can be debt free one day
twenty dollars against fifty thousand
that's right that's good math
that's not how often people go to
restaurants that's also doesn't take
into account the hours you could be
working instead of sitting in that
restaurant earning more the other way
right so anyway there's a whole
different conversation here this is just
a tough Spirit to work through and if
you have this attitude heading into any
problem in your life you're not going to
get solved this fatalistic attitude
isn't going to get us anywhere so we've
got to change our attitude change our
Behavior change our thoughts we're
rooting for you all out there this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Dr John deloney this
hour and we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five hey George this is awesome I heard
about this news John it's big time I'm
hoping I can get an invite to this
what's going on will not be invited
every time I talk about this event I get
more fired up because it's going to be
fantastic money and marriage is back and
this time instead of just one night it's
going to be an entire weekend where you
set up a marriage Retreat this fall me
and Rachel Cruz are going to be here in
Nashville for the money and marriage
getaway an entire weekend unplugged from
your day-to-day life simply focusing on
your marriage here's a deal it's in
October you have time to start planning
now financially you have time to start
planning for child care figure it out
you got a long run away on this one and
by the way
if you are three months into the new
year
and you've already blown it completely
this is a great way to pick up the back
half your year okay I guess the back the
final quarter of the year we're going to
cover things like money and budgeting
with your spouse we're going to talk
about connection sex and intimacy kids
the whole thing and we'll get you
planning for your future together and
this isn't what you think of when you
think of a marriage conference you're
going to learn a ton but we're also
going to give you and your spouse time
together throughout the weekend to
reflect on and discuss what you're
learning and Rachel and I will be there
to coach you and answer your questions
and we've got some rad surprises along
the way this is Nashville it's going to
be fun we have friends and guests going
to show up it's gonna be a blast if
you're listening and this sounds like
something you and your spouse need
um talk to your spouse about this
tickets are 6.99 a couple which is a
deal if you've ever been to a three-day
marriage conference it's a great
experience a deal especially here in
Nashville 6.99 a couple go to
ramseysolutions.com events to save your
spot ramseysolutions.com
slash events love it you and Whitney can
go I'll get you all half price tickets
I'll take that I don't know often get a
deal from you so thank you for thinking
of us I'll get you in I'll get you in I
hope so well if you're a new listener to
the show and you've been hearing us talk
about these baby steps and 3B and six
and what's going on here we want to give
you a deeper dive on this at
ramseysolutions.com all you need to do
is click on that get started button and
we'll help you know help you figure out
what that next best step is for your
financial Journey based on your
situation and where you're at today
that's ramseysolutions.com and click on
the get started button sorry about that
man I sneeze right here doing that man
it's all right I'm used to it I mean you
have a mute button just for everyone
listening out there it just comes
through your microphone and then
somebody's driving thinking they just
blew a tire while they're going down the
road that was me that was me oh boy all
right let's go to the phones Adam joins
us in Buffalo New York Adam welcome to
the show
Dr John thank you very much for taking
the call I appreciate it sure what's
your question so
I was recently fired for my job of 14
years
oh man can we pause right there for a
second
go ahead what was your job
I uh worked for a pet food manufacturer
if you ever gave your dogs like the most
popular pet food treats on the planet I
made them for you wow well on behalf of
George's two dogs that he treats better
than I treat my kids thank you their
food budget's bigger than mine pretty
awesome and in all seriousness
um you've probably heard me or Ken say
this but the
the research data says that when you get
fired from your job
it's as devastating to your body as
losing a loved one
it's overwhelming it's hard and so I
know it's really easy to be like all
right I'm back on the like man it's it
sucks and I'm sorry like just as your
friend I'm sorry them first few days
were really rough I pretty much stayed
in my room in the futile position trying
to figure out what I was going to do
with my future and yeah that's what I'm
coming to you guys with today is what do
I do moving forward from this I don't
want to work for anybody else I'd rather
start my own business I'm not leaving
there empty-handed and I use the baby
steps to get myself out of that and
actually save up and I I'm doing well
for myself it's just
what do I do now I'm lost very cool man
um well congratulations for setting
yourself up for this moment
um so I guess the magic questions are
what do you want to do
well here's the problem the thing that
I'm kind of passionate about and that I
want to do is one of the highest failure
businesses there is I'd like to go into
the restaurant business okay
tell me about I was
uh I was looking at two different
properties uh one's worth about 320 000
and the other one's worth about 250 000
and uh both of them are TurnKey
establishments ready to go
when I have like a 45 minute commute to
the other one I'd have you know five
minute commute to but one's got a lot
better population density and we're
drawing more people the other ones
closer to home and where I'm more known
and have a good name it's
yeah
I'm scared to dive ahead into this
you should yeah you should be um
I don't think that that that being your
next move is Super Wise
I'd much rather see you
go get a job in a restaurant and work
your way around that restaurant to make
sure this is what you want to do before
you go sink a quarter of a million
dollars into something
you're gonna find yourself I get it I
get it I get it real Dimensions I did
work in a restaurant when I was 19 years
old I did bus tables and I wash dishes
and I enjoyed the environment and stuff
like that but moving into a management
role and learning every single position
yes that's I think beyond the job
training would be smart and I'm actually
looking at that option but at the same
time I don't want to miss out on an
opportunity to buy a place that's not
going to be there a year do you have the
cash right now to buy that place
uh right now liquid I'm worth uh I have
ninety six thousand dollars in an
individual investment cow I have a
hundred and forty thousand dollars and a
401k we're not touching That We're Not
Gonna withdraw that to start this
business
all right and uh I have 51 000 coming in
a pension from uh from Nestle that my
former employer which I was gonna cash
that out and start the business because
that's not really going to grow much
more where it's at so but you would get
a 51 000 check straight to your account
that you can do what you want with
yes so I'm basically worth 150 liquid
right now plus fifteen thousand dollars
in my emergency fund and so let me say
this if Dave called me right now on my
cell phone and said hey John
um a buddy of mine is selling his 10
million dollar property and he's my
friend and he's gonna sell it for two
it's a deal it's an eight million dollar
discount but I don't want it but I know
you and your wife are looking for some
other property I got this for you give
them a call and it's yours for 2 million
I would have to tell them that's the
deal of a lifetime that would change my
family's future and I don't have two
million dollars so I can't buy this
thing
so you've got some you've got a deal in
your head
and you don't have the money to even
close that deal regardless of whether
it's a good deal or not and I'm I don't
think it's wise to do it I would love to
see you spend six months begin to heal
from getting laid off learn the
restaurant industry in your area get
tied in you did this when you're 19. I
did stuff when I was 19. you know what
else I do when I was 19 I went running a
lot I used to do Jiu Jitsu I couldn't
even touch my toes anymore man so like
we change over time I'd love to see you
get back in there and slow play this a
little bit you got some money so that if
things get tight you're gonna be able to
pay your bills you've done all the right
things
don't race out basically what you're
doing is you just got a divorce don't
run in and marry the first person you
just meet don't do that
spend some time healing spend some time
dating a little bit and then you're
gonna find somebody and talk to other
restaurant owners and see how they did
it and then the ones that you respect
and maybe you scale this thing up maybe
it starts with hey I'm gonna do a food
truck I'm gonna buy a truck with cash
and I'm gonna do this to see if it's a
viable option and I'm a scale up to a
restaurant once we have enough business
maybe it's a crowdfunded thing who knows
what you could do and how much money you
could save for the future but right now
this being like it's now or never man I
got the opportunity that is when a bad
decision gets made that and we see these
sad stories you've probably heard of
them these business owners and you said
the restaurant industry High turnover
rate for these things failing and when
you do it with debt it just adds insult
to injury
because now you have a failed business
and a pile of debt to deal with and
those are the same situations about one
of the properties that was kind of
making me lean towards it was there's an
apartment above and if I put a hundred
thousand dollars down on a mortgage
payment for this place then rent the
apartment out above the apartment above
actually pays the mortgage payment on it
and then I'm rolling I'm playing with
house model right where are you living
well currently right now I live at my
brother's house so okay that's not a
good long-term plan I think we got to
pause on this whole situation I want it
for you long term I wouldn't do it I can
hear it in your voice you're going to do
it anyway I'm just telling you when this
thing goes sideways call me in George
and we'll be here for you and I'm going
to be mean to you
but the chance of this not working is
strong to quite strong man take care of
yourself yeah thanks for the call that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to my co-host Dr John
deloney all the guys in the booth and
new America appreciate you listening
we'll be back real soon
okay
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell Ramsay personality also co-host
of smart money happy hour joined by my
friend Dr John Maloney catch him on his
own show the Dr John deloney show which
I uh can I say John is a great show you
know I I regret everything I said on
Twitter about it it really is a good
show lucky for you
um
I was gonna say I I I I wouldn't know
how to be on Twitter yeah that's why I
knew I knew you would never find it you
can just talk whatever you want that's
awesome and I like y'all's show too
um I was honored to be a guest on it was
fun yeah it was it was a one and done it
will never happen again you guys haven't
had me back yet which is super weird but
it's not a guest type shall we we
decided ah yeah after after I was after
you were the test run and we went no no
it's better just us the number of people
I dated in high school in college and
they're like I think I'm just gonna stay
single forever I'm good like uh wow not
doing that again uh I love it well hey
give us a call we're lonely here triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number to call we'd love to take
your questions today and Brittany has
decided to do that over in Miami
Brittany welcome to the show how can
John welcome to Miami what's up Brittany
good
um so I
I just found you guys
seeing everything about the baby steps
and everything on YouTube Welcome to the
crazy gang and you decided yeah I'm just
as weird I'm gonna call in welcome to
the cult yes is yes you can be just now
it could be weird one of my co-workers
says I'm spiraling but I think it's in a
good way
hey I assure you you are it's all good
welcome to the gang what's up
so I'm trying to decide what I just
shade off
um one of my loans is that this was
before I found the baby steps so it
wasn't my smallest loan but I paid it
off in cash
um it was uh like a 50 000 loan wow yeah
yeah so because I had a lot of savings
and I didn't know what to do with it and
I realized that I probably should be
putting it towards my debt so that's
what I started doing good for you
right so now I'm trying to decide the
next thing and I have a car loan but I
also have my student loan payments um
and I just realized that with this whole
the pause with student loans I've still
been making payments because there's no
interest but
um I'm wondering if I should pay off
that student loan that since interest
rates seems like they might be starting
back up soon
instead of the Cardinal even though it's
not the smallest loan yeah so you know
baby step two the debt snowball method
that we teach smallest balance the
largest balance regardless of the
interest rate but you're saying hey it's
zero percent interest wouldn't it make
more sense to knock this out while I'm
not having to accrue
right yeah because it looks I just
realized that I guess they're they're
going to start it back
60 days after June 30th or something
because I was hoping maybe they'll we'll
see we'll see they have a history of
kicking things uh down the road so would
not Shock me if they just keep extending
this thing to Oblivion but no I would I
would just attack that next smallest
balance regardless of the interest rate
and it's for a few reasons number one
you're going to feel that progress
you're gonna get there faster
mathematically
right okay right and when you ignore the
interest rate it just makes it a lot
simpler when you just have a stack of
debts and you go that next one's next
I'm going to make minimum payments on
the rest and I'm gonna sell stuff use
the side hustle money use my savings
except for the thousand dollars and get
rid of that so how what's your next debt
how big is it
um it's my car loan and it's like uh
thirty two thousand dollars right now
okay what's your income
uh 195 000. we love to hear that what do
you do Brittany
I'm an attorney oh I was gonna say are
they hiring I don't want that that's
bless you bless you attorneys out there
that's a great that's awesome so here's
the thing that how quickly are you going
to pay off this car a few months
I want to try to pay it off yeah within
this year so I want to just attack I
just um started taking uh I put zero
percent for my 401k instead of the 10 or
11 percent wow you pause the investing
I'm so proud that's when it really it
gets real how much savings do you have
right now Brittany
now after I just made that payment of
like 50 000 I have like 19
000 in savings so if we used this sounds
crazy I know but you called the crazy
people what if you used 18 of that 19
and threw it at the car
yeah that's what I was thinking I didn't
know if I should use it to the student
loans or the car but I guess I guess I
got to do the math and see how long it
would take well then you have what 14
left on the car and how much are you
able to throw at the debt each month
how many thousands of dollars
I think I could
try to do the math because right now I'm
paying 600 a month I think I can put an
additional like a 1500 now that I'm not
putting it towards the 401K you make 195
Grand there should be like five or six
years yeah your student loans what do
you spend the money on well I also have
a mortgage um how much
well it's not that it's uh well the 50
000 I pay was actually because I took
out like a piggyback mortgage for my
when I bought the condo okay which was
to pay for the down payment
um so now that's out of the way and now
my
um mortgage is like 18 30. but you're
bringing home about 10 grand a month or
so
now that you've paused the question yeah
and I also have um it's a condo so the
homeowners association fees are like a
little over a thousand dollars which you
have a monthly Association if you have a
thousand bucks in Miami
yep oh goodness gracious welcome to
Miami indeed for real okay that's most
people's rents but still yeah let's
here's what I would love to see you do
and I'm saying this because I think I
have am probably the person who loves
lawyers the most in this country who's
not an attorney because I spent so much
time working work you're the only one I
mean people who talk bad about like you
guys just show up when people need
somebody in their corner so you're a
gift
um there's idiots in every industry but
um I also know that you're trained to
over analyze things and to be overly
analytical and to second guess your
second guesses and then third guess
those guesses
right and then to also seek counsel
that's the whole gig and so you're going
to get 40 different strong opinions from
40 different people
exactly exactly what if instead of doing
all that you said I will find seven
thousand dollars a month and pay this
car off in two months
could you look at your take home and and
literally not go out not go to a
restaurant pay pay
um the minimums on your mortgage pay the
minimums on your on your association
fees whatever those are and scratch and
Claw yours for for 60 days and have no
car payment and have one big debt left
could you do that okay
I also wanna because I I
know hold on hold on you're you're
lawyering me now just yeah yeah just
answer the question
I think so you said seven thousand a
month could you do that
um yeah yeah I think so I have to look
at I think I think you can figure it out
even if you have to take a case on the
side or pick up an extra case or go mow
some Lawns and drive Uber or something
and I know you're like I make 200 000 a
year I'm not driving anywhere it might
be that moment here's why I would love
for you to look up in May
and have no car payment none and then
you have proven to yourself I'm Brittany
I can do anything and instead of I think
so we're gonna make it a no-sew because
I'm gonna give you every dollar and FPU
you're going to be doing a monthly
budget on paper you're going to see all
these numbers you're going to figure out
ways to shave to get more money thrown
at that debt and I want you to call us
back when you're debt free thanks so
much for the call
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsay show I'm George
Campbell joined by Dr John deloney this
hour the number to call to ask your
question is triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jane joins us up next
in Lawton Oklahoma Jane welcome to the
show
Hi how are you we're doing great how can
we help you today
oh okay so this is tough
um so I've been married about two years
and before we got married I agreed to
not sharing the bank account
I understood his reservations
I do have a full-time job
all right
um and a couple of months ago I thought
well maybe I really do need to learn to
manage my finances better because
according to him like I haven't proven
that I know how to manage money
and I started listening to the Dave
Ramsey Show because I thought that you
know I knew of the Ramsay Network and I
have realized that my problems are a lot
more intense than I really than than
just a financial disagreement or a
communication issue
um
you know he's gone
half of the time with his job and he
doesn't leave he will not give me money
for groceries any Necessities
um anytime I bring that up he tells me I
need to manage my money better do you
have a debit card
do I have a debit card how much money
like control and access does he give you
to money
oh zero so you can't spend a dime if you
even wanted to
no I mean I have my like my paycheck but
that's it okay and you're working
full-time
yes do you have any kids I mean I have
one daughter how old is she
uh 10. okay is he the dad no okay
um
or
are you safe
yeah
I mean physically yes
how uh I
all right I'm gonna trust you the the
data suggests that guys who act like
this are
uh physically abusive as well
and I would even go as far to say maybe
hasn't thrown a punch but has created a
world
that is so unsafe for your body that it
shuts itself down and tries to get small
because there's a bear living in that
house
alive but like on paper that would be
way worse than this I've never had a
panic attack until recently so I know
like full-on like panic attack okay
and I know like I'm educated enough to
know that like your body starts to do
things when it's trying to get your
attention yeah right so what's keeping
you there
well I mean I do I mean I did make a vow
to him
and I take that seriously but I mean I
have a couple of thousand dollars in
debt now that I didn't have before
because I have to put gas and groceries
on credit cards sometimes
do you know he makes about four times
what I do sure
I I don't want to weave this back and
forth into a finance situation than out
of a finance situation urine is
extremely toxic environment
you're in an unsafe environment and if
we haven't crossed lines yet we will at
some point
and when even when the way you started
the call he told me I haven't proven my
like just those words alone let me know
this is very much a
father-daughter relationship far far
more than it's a husband and wife
creating a future together
right I mean
he I mean if he he does control
everything I mean not just money and if
something's not up to none the way he
wants it done I mean he will threaten to
put me out
yes why are you I mean trivial stuff
like that
which I mean this doesn't sound like a
marriage if you just talk hearing you
say this out loud just sounds like toxic
roommate situation
what is he actually signing up for when
he signed up for this marriage
I don't think love should feel like this
it does not this is control this is
power
and I I this is this is I'm speaking on
behalf of John deloney on behalf of the
Ramsay Network here and so
um I I take a much broader view of the
word fidelity
I think you can cheat on somebody and
never sleep with another person but if
you steal from somebody their dignity
and their autonomy and their ability to
have feelings and thoughts and a and a
uh partnership in a relationship that's
not Fidelity right you are cheating that
person out of their life
you're achieving that person out of
connection okay and so I take a much
broader view I think and some people are
very narrow like you gotta have sex with
somebody else otherwise it's not
cheating I I I have a much broader view
than that but I'm listening to my sister
Jane here
and you're slowly drowning and you know
it your body's trying to get your
attention and so I guess what George and
I are asking you
um two guys who love our wives and we're
not perfect man but
I I I'm I'm trying to sit across the
table from you and say why are you what
are you doing why are you here why are
you staying what's the hook
you got a couple thousand dollars who
cares
you're too tough and resilient and brave
you'll have that paid off in no time
like something else is here like what's
the hook why are we staying
I mean I don't know that I could
well I mean some of it's like I want to
say that like I I gave my all and I
don't think you're being allowed to give
your all because the person you're
connected to is saying you can take your
all and flush it down the toilet
go make the bed the right way
are you scared to leave what would be
the repercussions if you said hey I'm
out
I mean
I mean I just want a stable wife for my
child
this is not it
your child is absorbing
top to bottom what love looks like what
marriage looks like
what uh equality looks like
absorbing it in into their DNA
now I I will never unless somebody is
being physically like assaulted I'm not
going to tell somebody they have they
need to leave their marriage
I've often told people you need to get
to where you are safe and we may need to
take a structured 30-day break
I'm gonna go move in with a friend for
30 days we're going to be very clear on
when I come when I come back with the
conditions of coming back are going to
be but
um and again you're you and I that's you
got to make this Choice you're you're an
adult I don't see that going over well
do you see your current situation going
over well
well I mean I probably wouldn't have
reached out to you guys I know I know I
know
and I hope you hear that we love you I'm
worried about neither options are easy
let's just make that very clear staying
is really hard and leaving is going to
be hard but one leads you to where
you're free
and that your daughter's safe and you're
safe and you can get to a better place
financially instead of living in this
prison
and we just want what's best for Jane
yeah
to make a decision and
[Music]
do you have people who that you know and
trust that can sit with you and hear the
the entirety of the story
a little bit have you opened up do they
know
yeah
what do they tell you
to leave okay if your friend was in the
situation what would you tell her
I mean I I never imagined myself in a
situation
um that's what makes these abusive
situations so surreal because it's like
there's no way that's happening I I've
heard that over and over that there's no
way this is happening to me and it may
even be in your case happening again
right
yeah I've never experienced anything
quite like this
calm
but I'm just scared of I I'm I'm really
just I don't know what I mean I know
what I need to do
but here's what I want you to do I want
you to reach out to a couple of friends
to reach out to a local counselor in
your community not to go quote unquote
get well right now but you need someone
that's going to walk alongside you as
you have a very challenging road ahead
of you whether you stay and try to
figure out how to make this thing work
or you decide to create an alternative
life outside of this relationship but
listen you're worth being well
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
whether one
their watch and guarantee and
and always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney if you are tuning in the last
segment we talked to Jane in Oklahoma
going through a really dark financially
abusive situation and just wanted to
update you guys that we have connected
her with one of our in-house Financial
coaches that can walk with her for an
extended period of time and make sure
that she's okay but I know I know some
direct inroads to some
resources there in their local community
my heart my heart's broken for her so
much there so much there well let's do
the question of the day let's get to it
John that'll uh bring some levity to
this show today's question comes from
Peter in California and I'm told by our
producer James this is a real question I
just want to preface that we didn't make
this up Peter says I'm a citizen of
California and I just thought of an
ingenious way any U.S adult citizen may
be able to come up with millions of
dollars and I want to see if you think
it would be a dumb idea can I stop you
right there yes probably a dumb idea
well let's let's hear his hypothetical a
million dollar uh ingenious scheme the
idea is to build a great credit score
then open a credit card with all 4 236
banks in the U.S you would already need
to be making payments on a house and own
a car so you wouldn't need credit
anymore then you simply simply max out
all 4 236 credit cards by cash advancing
to the max on every card with how how
many ever ATMs it takes this would leave
you with almost 22 million dollars in
Cold Hard Cash if for example the Max on
each card was five thousand dollars you
would just need to make sure the bank
your house is in doesn't have a credit
card on it I understand you can't be
criminally prosecuted for Consumer Debt
and they can't even come after you at
all after six years but they can try
pushing a lawsuit against you is this a
dumb idea or truly ingenious
if anyone wonders how's our Public
Schools doing these days let this be
exhibit a for not great are they
teaching in California
this is the result of uh teach to the
test right here guys teach to the test
do you think this is like an 18 year old
or is this like an older guy who hatched
another plan in all honesty we get a lot
of grief for oversimplifying things and
for uh you know talking down like down
to P like we just make everything so
simple this is why these are questions
that we get
these are questions so we're going to
try to explain again we are not experts
on the banking industry and on credit
card you know how the inner workings of
that but I'll tell you what we do know
that's what we do know
um this won't work even if you wanted it
to not even close
and if it did you wouldn't want it so
number one all four thousand two hundred
thirty six Banks I'm just using Peter's
number I don't know if that's how many
banks there are they few only a few of
them actually issue cards in many banks
that do issue cards issue them through
other Banks they're a pass through so
All 4 236 banks in the US are not
issuing credit cards they might issue a
line of credit to a particular person or
they might issue a debit card that's
just your own money so that's problem
number one number two
very few cards if any will let you take
out the full cash advance amount and so
if your credit limit's five grand you
can't take out five grand in cash
advance it might be like 1500 bucks
there you go and
after you took out the fourth card or
the fifth card every time you take out a
credit card they pull your credit they
run a credit report at some point the
bank's gonna go uh no this guy's got 48
cards open this guy's trying to open a
bunch of cards his total a bit his
ability to get himself into trouble is
now gone twenty thousand twenty five
thousand thirty thousand thirty five up
to 22 million
and here's the even stupider part that
cash advance that you took out on that
card has a higher interest rate so even
if you hypothetically had 22 million
dollars in cash you now owe 20 something
percent on 22 million dollars but he's
saying I don't care after six years I'll
go away
oh boy well aside from integrity and and
fraud this is fraught with stupidity if
nothing else just get a freaking job
dude
that's some angry Boston right I've been
hanging out with Ken Coleman all those
10 words finally rubbed off on me man
okay well hey hey Peter good job uh I
come I mean literally like
good job yeah
um if you use this kind of mental
gymnastics on something for good you
could be like the nest the next Elon
Musk exactly and and
senators and House Representatives
can we please get serious about fixing
the U.S education system because it's
it's it's dysfunctional and the U.S
credit system and debt system which is
the most marketed product in the world
and America is number one at debt like
no other we're the best I just heard a
clip from a Dax Shepard's podcast and
one of the actors on there was like I'm
into New Zealand you there's no credit
score like we can't I came to America
and they're like here's debt you need to
take out debt you got to build a credit
score and even he was like this is
insane why are we do so he's like I just
keep spending because they tell me I
need to spend
he doesn't even understand it hey uh we
are the best at that America's number
one at a lot of things and debt is at
the top of that list so hey gold gold
stars way to go America oh my goodness
hey that's uh job security for us John
we'll be helping out we'll be helping
out Peter when he calls in and says I'm
22 million dollars in credit card debt
please help I thought it was going to be
an awesome scheme all right you can't go
inside of a restaurant for the next 1400
years Peter well the good news is John
this sounds like it could have been your
idea 15 years ago 100 that's hey this is
why I'm so sad because I've actually sat
down on a piece of paper been like hey I
think what if I think I've got a plan
goodness all right well whoever our next
caller is is definitely smarter than
Peter so looking forward to talking to
you hello bar Jasmine in Long Island
Jasmine welcome to the show save the
show Jasmine save the show
hi so I've actually been on the show
before
um welcome from my own personal issue
but thank you but this time I'm calling
back on behalf of my mom so I've been
I've been tackling on my baby stuff too
um I'm doing Financial Peace University
and we just finished off
um the insurance one which is very
interesting
um because I didn't know a lot of kind
of what
I didn't know anything about insurance
really I agree I'm underrated lesson
very important yes
so my mom she is 51 and she's on
Medicare she has epilepsy and she's able
to work there's nothing too severe or
her medicine
um takes up a lot of her income probably
it's probably like 200 a bottle every
month she has three bottles
um so that's she basically is living
paycheck to paycheck because she can't
work
um she can't work overtime she can't she
can only work and start them out she
can't she can't have so much of an
income
um and I really want to help her
kind of excuse me being in my journey I
want to kind of help her out and guiding
her and how she can kind of be liberated
from this I don't want her to have to be
living with music to paycheck every
single service to her life and she was
in those View and you kind of music do I
so I don't want to see where how I can
really go about it because I know that
health insurance can pay for it but I
don't really know so she's Limited in
income due to Medicare but you're saying
hey if she let's say she doesn't take
Medicare she earns more than that she
wouldn't be able to afford health
insurance at that point
she can get regular health insurance
that will be able to have some policy
for her for her medicine she still has
to pay her health insurance that she
will still be she'll be able to make
more and be able to save and kind of
budget out her medicine with her rent
and all that yeah so it's saying hey if
we get off the government assistance and
we're able to work more we might be able
to afford this and that's the kind of
conundrum you're here for
yeah have y'all looked to shop some of
these at um our friend Mark Cuban's Cost
Plus Pharmacy or rx.com and see if
there's an opportunity for some of these
assistance programs to lower the cost of
drugs I I don't know of the particular
ones in Long Island but I know that
they've got
they've got programs at the county level
at the city level at the state level at
the federal level and then they've got
these new pharmacies that are coming
online that are designed entirely for
people in your mom's situation
okay there's also the Epilepsy
Foundation they have assistance that can
provide free or low-cost medication as
well so I think just start doing your
homework start crunching the numbers and
see what makes sense but check on Cost
Plus Drug Company yes that's Marx and
he's a trustworthy guy and check out
rx.com too but we're wishing you guys
the best and hoping that if she can get
off that government assistance and have
a better life because of it I am all for
that this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George camel
joined by Dr John deloney this hour open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five well every time you
hear someone do their debt free scream
on this show it's because they finally
reached a point where they said I've had
it I'm not living like this anymore and
when you get to that place that is when
your life will change too
a lot of you out there are scared to
death you're overwhelmed because your
money problems feel too big to solve but
you can be in control of your money and
it starts when you draw that Line in the
Sand and you decide to make some radical
changes you've got to rethink how you
handle your money and we'll show you
exactly how to do that in Financial
Peace University this is our Flagship
nine week money course where you will
learn step by step the plan on how to
beat debt how to build a real lasting
wealth nearly 10 million people have
changed their lives with FPU
I'm included in that bunch and lots of
them have ended up right here on our
debt free stage and you can do it too
don't go another day feeling scared and
out of control just say I've had it and
Take Back Control you can start
Financial base University at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com
FPU Mary is up next in Scottsdale Mary
welcome to the show
hi thank you absolutely how can we help
[Music]
quite a while
um
trying to get out of debt but the
medical bills keep rolling in and we
have um we have a couple of kids that
have some medical
challenges and we are looking at about
another hundred thousand dollars in
medical bills this year
um
and
we
yeah I'm just trying to figure out where
in our late 40s and early 50s and just
trying to figure out like if we're ever
going to be able to start saving for
retirement because we can't you know
we're trying to follow the baby steps
and not start that until after we finish
paying off our debts but the debts just
don't ever what what are the nature of
the medical challenges
foreign
well a couple of our kids have had some
different things going on but right now
the biggest thing is
um our youngest son has the mental
health challenges okay
um and I had to stop working for a while
to stay home with him and then that kind
of perpetuated some of our debt um and
then
um we
yeah we just have some
treatments that he has to have coming up
that
are are going to cost quite a bit of
money even with the insurance that we
have
it's a hundred thousand dollars in
addition to your insurance
covered by insurance
there should be an average pocket max
our insurance doesn't cover
um
mental health a lot of mental the mental
health
parts
have you looked into other insurance
options that might cover it that could
bring this these bills down
no we haven't is there a cash pay option
that would make it cheaper
no this is the cash pay option for
there's
there's different treatment
um throughout the year so
I'm so sorry so I I normally I would dig
in a little bit further and but I can
tell that
you want to keep this surface level am I
am I right and that's perfectly okay
yeah yeah okay so
um in order to preserve anonymity I mean
the
tough answer that we have for you is
whether it's a roof that you know has to
be replaced or really challenging
medical expenses coming up or the birth
of a new kid or a car that's failing all
of those things we're going to look down
the road and say okay
what's coming our way and how much is
that going to cost and is there anything
we can do to mitigate that cost
and when we figure out after we've
exhausted anything we can do then we
just have to look at we have to as hard
as this is we have to just own reality
here's how much we make here's how much
we bring home in this house and here's
how much this is going to cost and we're
gonna have to adjust our lifestyle we're
going to adjust our retirement planning
to deal with the right what's right in
front of us and it feels while you're in
the middle of it like
here's what you sound like you sound
exhausted
and it almost sounds like your question
is existential more than it is
mathematical like how long do I have to
keep doing this
is that fair
yeah
I'm sorry
thank you
just as a dad of two kids I I'm just I'm
heartbroken for you
thank you
Mary what what's y'all's income
household
it's about 175 000. okay what other debt
do you have outside of medical expenses
we just have
that needs to be paid off yeah um could
you knock out the card this month so
no no
I mean with all
without costs um I mean because we have
medications I have to be
paid for
um
anyway we have
fifty thousand dollars in mostly medical
bills and then a small amount of the the
credit card
um or we don't use anymore we don't use
that at all anymore okay well I think
your best shot at dealing with this is
not having any debt outside of trying to
deal with these medical bills and so
that's what my A1 would be if I'm in
your shoes let's get rid of these credit
cards let's cut them up close the
accounts let's focus on trying to cash
flow as much of this uh Health stuff as
possible let's be in tight communication
with the hospitals and the doctors and
site and the billing departments you
better know them by first name and go
hey we're trying we can't pay this right
now what does this look like in worst
case scenario down the line you can't
pay it we negotiate these they go to
collections you got to just take care of
your family right now and and tell them
to kick rocks and pound sand if they
start calling you
um sometimes medical uh
again I'm trying to be respectful at the
same time trying to trying to help out
best I can
um is part of this cost some sort of
specialized addiction treatment
okay
um I would be
really intentional about saying okay we
might not be able to afford Place X in
place y or we might not be able to
afford
um you know there's disorder eating
clinics that are basically concierge
services that are second to none that
everybody's got an individualized
counselor and psychologist and
physiologist and nutritionist and then
there's some that are going to be more
group oriented that are going to be
lower cost it may be that we want the
best here we want the the goals Diamond
standard and we're just not going to be
able to do it this time we're going to
have to go with one that we can afford
so maybe instead of a hundred thousand
dollar treatment maybe it is a forty
thousand dollar treatment or maybe it's
a 50 whatever that looks like for you
all and I know you guys have been on
that road but I do think there's some
hard conversations to be had around
just because it's the most expensive
doesn't always mean it's the best and
just because it is less expensive
doesn't mean it's cheap doesn't mean
it's it's no good
um and I would really explore some of
those options even if they take you out
of Scottsdale and they take uh one of
you and your kid or just your kid by
themselves for the the duration of the
treatment time
um to another place but I think it's
worth exploring every possible option
and not just saying we have to have the
Cadillac in this situation and George
that's hard because this is your kids
and I want to do the best of the best of
the best of the best for my kids
and I think the assumption is anything
less than the best of the best of the
best is somehow inferior
that's right and it's just inaccurate
well I have so much empathy out of all
the types of debt you can find yourself
in so much empathy for medical debt no
one's asking to bring on medical debt
that's right and so I just my heart goes
out to Mary and I'm hoping the best that
this is not a long-term thing that we we
get through this season then we have a
pile of debt we clean it up we have a
great income and we can move forward
with our lives and retire one day so
we're cheering you on Mary thanks so
much for the call and trusting us with
this situation that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books my thanks
to my co-host Dr John deloney all the
guys in the booth and you America we
appreciate you listening until next time
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm here with my
good friend Dr John deloney and we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's kick
off this hour with our friend Matthew
Cross across the line there over in
Canada Yonder ways Matthew Cross
across the line across the line across
the country there's no Pond there so I
had to say line I didn't know how to say
it Matthew welcome to the show I'm sorry
that I exist
all right how are you guys we're doing
well how can we help today
okay so before I ask my question there's
a bit of context that I Gotta Give so
I'm 16 years old I work full-time and I
do that on a part-time schedule so I'm
doing 12 to 13 hours a day uh three to
four days a week because I'm still in
school full-time oh so my part time you
just mean you're not doing this five
days a week yeah yeah exactly I was like
what kind of Life Hack is this so you're
working full-time part-time
yeah but I got it um but anyway I pay
for most of my own stuff I bought my own
car I paid for my insurance my gas my
phone plan a lot of my own food even
especially on the days where I'm working
and on top of this my parents have
decided that it's fair uh to charge 15
of my income as a rent or tax or
uh whatever you want to call it now you
guys are smarter than me you don't have
anything in in this so I'd like to know
whether or not you think that's fair or
I'm just overreacting and thinking that
it isn't
so how much do they want to charge you
uh it's 15 of my income so this month
it'll be close to five hundred dollars
and you're you're 16.
16.
I don't know what the laws are in Canada
but I don't think in America you would
have legal standing to charge a minor
rent
I don't think it is legal but
you know what's what's the motive behind
it have you just had a conversation with
them and say hey what's what's going on
here
why all of a sudden do you want rent
money like are they broke do they need
money no no it's okay it's kind of
interesting because for my dad he says
it is about the money he says it's not
fair that he should be the only person
to like provide for the family when he
has working children right
um
hold on
you're here because of him
you didn't ask to be here he brought you
into the world
yeah that's you should tell him Josh you
say well well well if it isn't
the consequences of your actions dad
the reason he thinks that's fair is when
he was a kid he had to pay 50 of his
income right and he probably had to walk
up and down uphill nude in the snow to
school both ways like whatever like
I could grieve okay um and then then
there's my mother she she has a slightly
different side she doesn't think that
um it's about the money it's about well
according to her
realize there's rent there's expenses
and whatnot and this is real life so
this is what we're teaching you all
right so let me let me push back on that
on that for our general audience
um there was a great Camp right a camp
was a name for a mixed martial arts
school
um called shoot a box out of Brazil and
they had some of the greatest fighters
in the world
um Vandal like Silva was out of there
Shogun who was that I mean it was just
the Who's Who and they were known for
having practices where they just beat
the tar out of each other they would do
really intense workouts they do really
intense
um physical training but they would just
fight every day and they were known for
being the most intense fighters in the
ring maniacal like they would win fights
before they even got in there and I
never missed a Shogun fight and never
missed a vandalized silver fight I never
missed shoebox shoebox fights because
they were so I mean they were so
entertaining to watch they were just
insane and
those guys career was significantly
curtailed
because the idea was you're gonna get
hit in the ring so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna hit you a bunch before
you get in the ring
and that's going to make you better in
the ring and that works for a very short
window of time
until all that cumulative damage makes
you where you can't even climb up in the
ring anymore and now 15 20 years later
almost all of the gyms have very limited
full-on contact sparring
they saved the hits for the gym and so I
am sick of parents saying well I'm going
to hit you now because the world's gonna
hit you later as though that's gonna
help you later
what I want to do is give you a context
what love looks like and connectivity
looks like so in the world hits you in
the face you are anchored into something
way stronger and I'm not talking about
making soft weak kids I'm not it's not
it at all but we don't have to go all
the way over here where I'm gonna start
charging you right now because one day
it's going to charge you rent they're
going to show you how you clearly
Matthew
clearly
are light years ahead of people your own
age I don't know any 16 year olds who
are where you're at right now paying
cash for their cars covering their own
gas and insurance buying their own meals
so the right idea that you actually go
ahead I did actually borrow money from
my sister to buy my car but I I did pay
her off two days ago actually good so
here's the other side of this there's
not a lot you can do
yeah that's fair and so
um here's where this breaks my heart is
the moment you turn 18 you're probably
gone
and they will have lost the relationship
and influence with their son and I hope
that it's not too late for them
foreign
but if I'm you I'm probably gonna wait
I'm gonna abide my time until I'm 18 and
then they won't ever see me again I'm
out of here
and I hate that for all of y'all because
I I it's just not healthy or good for
anybody but that's the world they're
creating
and I don't know that you have another
option unless you're gonna move out at
16 which I don't know that's a wise deal
too
um are you in high school right now
uh yeah I am I mean you're an impressive
kid I would just be proud if I was your
parents yeah but here's here's the deal
the other side of this is you go all
right I'll just stop working and what
happens then they have to cover all of
your bills plus they get zero dollars in
rent yeah what is that what sounds a lot
like the Canadian government which is
going to penalize you for the better you
do all right they're just going to keep
penalizing you more and more what if you
said hey I really want to focus on
school Dad I'm not going to work anymore
and I now I need money to cover all
these bills
what would they say
uh they would just cut off everything
you wouldn't be you wouldn't have a car
anymore you wouldn't have a phone you
wouldn't have gas you'd get zero dollars
yes do you help out around the house
taking care of the house
I try to but not usually which is
another reason why they say they charge
it because
like like I said like I'm gone but when
the sun comes up to like everybody's in
bed when I get home because you're in
school and work and then working your
tail off
yeah exactly this whole thing just feels
arbitrary to me yeah so I'm gonna have a
few conversations with them to get to
the heart of what this really is about
because if it's just like I'm gonna
financially abuse you because that's
what my dad did and it made me the man I
am today that's just bad parenting it's
just to put that on yourself sorry man
I'm sorry
um I can't think of
they should be cheering you on until
they are hoarse and I'm sorry that
they're penalizing you for being a
go-getter and uh I hope this doesn't
ruin your relationship long term man
because we all gonna need each other
down the road but I'm just heartbroken
for you my man absolutely but you're a
minor you live in their house and it's
their rules
thanks for the call man this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney if you like this show which I
assume you do if you're still listening
please consider subscribing leaving a
review and sharing this show with
friends that is how we continue to make
an impact on this toxic culture we are
up against every day and we so
appreciate all of you who have already
subscribed and left reviews and shared
it with so many people
so John uh a video stumbled across my
page from producer James and I thought
it was a great video for both of us to
talk about okay and it's with uh the
very intelligent Dr Jordan Peterson on
an interview he did on some guy's
YouTube channel great who has like a
bajillion followers no not some guy so I
wanted to play this clip and get your
take on it let's do it
you know because people say I'd be happy
if I had 400 million dollars it's like
you think you could handle that
responsibility do you like you're so
sure that that all of a sudden you'd
have all this money dumped on your
you can't even control your household
budget you live from paycheck to
paycheck now somebody's going to dump a
treasure on your
steps and that's going to fix your life
it's like okay how much you're going to
give to your relatives
like none oh that'll work out really
well
too much
so then you're going to take away their
responsibility from the Mario and you're
going to get that balance exactly right
and then what are you going to do with
that money because as soon as you got
the money the parasites are going to
come in and take your money yeah it
happens unbelievably quickly you know
you'll see while the average family
fortune lasts three generations that's
all
because money sitting around not being
carefully monitored it's like water it
just it's just
yeah man here's my initial thoughts on
that George one is
um
I would say this is a cultural issue but
I think it's as old as time this idea
that happiness is over there
um joy and satisfaction is somewhere
where I'm not and I always want to
caveat that with
um if you're struggling to eat
financially yes happiness is where I'm
not hungry right so there's some reality
that if you're being abused or you're in
a relationship somebody's cheating on
you or something yes happiness is not in
this right
um but as he was saying
if I just had a million dollars if I
just had 10 million dollars if I just
had 100 million dollars then fill in the
blank and I think him calling those
things out it's it's not accurate that's
not true
um because as we all know like wherever
you go you go with you and so you're
going to be you with the same
insecurities you just got 400 million
dollars to try to wallpaper and duct
tape over man the numbers just get
magnified and the as the great Biggie
Smalls said no money more problems right
there is a reality to that there is some
truth you can you can buy a plane and
get places faster and you can don't have
to worry about food great you have to
worry about your dad saying I'm never
talking to you again you have to worry
about your brother coming out of the
woods and saying hey give me this and
your cousin and that one friend you had
like it's the the problems and
challenges are just unique and different
but it all goes back to this core issue
happiness and joy is where I'm not and I
think if you can find happiness and joy
where you are then as he said um that's
no biblical Prince able be trustworthy
with a little and you'll be trustworthy
with a lot and it rarely Works in
Reverse well and I love your talk on how
winning won't make you well and I feel
like so much of our society is just
going well if I had more money John
everything would be so much greater and
like you said if you're like in a
poverty situation more money will change
your situation better and anybody who
says otherwise is lying and most people
that hear this are not those people
right but they go John no I've dude oh
I'll take 400 million dollars today I
think I know I could handle it dude I
would too and I wouldn't know it was
going to come with some very significant
challenges yeah and even change the
numbers 400 million is obviously an
insane number right but even take four
million four million a million yeah 500
000 and now you have the relationship
issues because everyone feels like
that's not fair that you got this I
should get a cut I raised you I'm your
aunt I'm your cousin
oh you're too good for us now because
you're it just changes stuff so there's
two pieces of this equation number one
is the contentment issue of going like
if I just had this over and it's over
there the other piece is a stewardship
issue of going why would you get more to
manage when you can't manage what you
already have right and we're talking to
you know the middle class and above here
we're talking to the people who make 40
50 60 250 Grand and still live paycheck
to paycheck right and they're going if I
made more money that's the problem
inflation John the cost of eggs I talked
to a guy the other day we did a man on
the street and he was like well how's
anyone supposed to afford rent with cost
of eggs and I go you're really gonna sit
here and blame eggs being three dollars
more as to why no one can get ahead in
America right and so there's a
stewardship and contentment issue and we
say money makes you more of who you
already are it just magnifies to magnify
so if you're a broke person who's a jerk
you're just going to be a rich jerk
later on in life and if you're a
generous person who doesn't have a lot
when you do have some you're going to be
a philanthropist right and um it's an
interesting uh if you just said you know
a financial advisor I saw this on
Twitter and it was a great exercise they
say I like to ask my clients this helps
me know exactly where they're at if you
had 20 years and 10 million dollars what
would you do
and just to see how they would spend
that money what they would do helps get
to the root of what they really value
and you've said show me your bank
account and your calendar and I'll show
you what you think what you think is
important yeah and so money is just a
tool it's not it's not a moral issue
money's amoral it's like a brick you can
use it to build buildings or throw it
through windows and so when you finally
figure out how to use it as a tool for
good it changes the way we see money yes
and if you were to look at my bank
account you would say man that guy
really values guitars and gummy candies
and that's okay you're doing it debt
free John
okay it's not okay all right let's go to
yazmarie in Boston my hometown yazmery
welcome to the show
hi how you doing
um good thank you uh so my question is
I'm 15 years old
and I'm currently trying to save up for
a car and I have about 800 that I have
saved and my parents said that they will
match whatever I end up saving awesome
and I'm just wondering whether I should
put the money in a CD or in a high-yield
savings account
um and which way will help it grow
faster over the next year and a half
love that question well uh I'm a big fan
of the high yield savings account over
the CD and it's for a very simple reason
the money stays liquid and if you needed
that money for any reason car or
otherwise you're going to be dinged with
a penalty in that CD and the other thing
is the CD has a fixed interest rate so
let's say the CD it'll give you four
percent right now
that's about what you'd get well the
problem is what if your high-yield
savings account goes to five percent
because it's a variable rate well now
you're missing out because your money's
locked up for the next 12 to 18 months
in a CD instead of growing even more in
that in that high yield savings account
okay and let me also say this it doesn't
make all of that difference when we're
talking about one year and a few
thousand dollars that's the timeline
we're looking at right
yeah when would you be getting a car how
how long from now
so I can get my permit when I'm 16 so by
December in December of this year
I can get my permit so are you hoping to
save up like two thousand dollars and
then your parents are going to get put
in two and buy a four thousand dollar
car or something like that
yeah I'm just trying to get a reasonable
car the other thing too is I don't have
a job and I'm just trying to find some
low stressed things I can do that won't
interfere with my schools and stuff okay
so we're talking evenings and weekends
yeah probably but I'm just not sure what
types of jobs I could potentially get at
15 in this area I mean I think retail
and Hospitality are great options
that's what I did at your age I'd even
work at the school that I was going to
even over the summer I was kind of
worked as an I.T person help you know
fixing updated computers and I worked at
Burger King for years I mowed lawns on
and also had it worked for part time
with the landscape company also was a
maintenance guide at a local church and
so
um I I want to challenge all young
people unless you have some very clear
personal challenges don't look for a
quote unquote the lowest stress job
go ahead and get a job where you can
work really hard and Shine the brightest
even when you're tired and I think
there's something that's really powerful
about what you can discover about
yourself in those in those positions I
was a doctor's office receptionist at 15
and I was making 12 bucks an hour and I
thought
I am rich and I just work you know we
paid 425. but it was enough and so start
to look around your community and see
hey what would pay the most and give me
the most experience or whatever you're
looking to do later in life or just what
would give me the best paycheck right
now if you want to be an attorney
someday see if you can get a job just
getting coffee in a legal shop right or
if something you may want to do like
work in a doctor's office if you want to
go to med school someday and just set a
goal and say hey I'm trying to save
three grand my parents will match it
that'll get me to six and start
researching what kind of cars could I
get for six grand and uh you'll be there
in no time and maybe you wait a little
longer and save up even more we're
cheering you on this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Dr John deloney
let me ask you a question have you ever
met a natural born leader Oh I thought
you could see Natural Born Killer that's
different Natural Born leader this one's
rhetorical no you haven't there's no
such thing because leaders are built
they are not born and the great thing
about that is that you get to decide
what kind of leader you're going to be
so if you want to take your leadership
to the next level join thousands of
Business Leaders who have already
grabbed their seats for entree
Leadership Summit it's happening May
30th through June 2nd in Nashville
Tennessee uh right here in our hometown
you're going to learn from some of the
best minds and Business Leaders like
Malcolm Gladwell Dr Jordan Peterson
manichohan Willie Robertson and so many
more this is not a leadership conference
you can afford to miss it's a game
changer for leaders and business owners
and that's why it's already almost sold
out so if you want to learn more about
entree Leadership Summit just go to
ramseysolutions.com
Summit that's ramseysolutions.com
Summit I went in uh I was up in the
entree floor a little while ago and they
have a thermometer it is it is almost
sold out man the energy on the entree
leadership floor is electric that's yes
and they love nothing more than serving
business owners and Business Leaders
like you all so looking forward to that
event John you're going to be speaking
there yes yes yes yes do you know what
you're speaking about yet I do oh all
right I won't let the cat out of the bag
good but it's gonna be good you're
always a favorite with that correct well
I'm looking forward to it to be fun all
right let's get to the phones triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number to call Judy joins us in
Denver Judy welcome to the Ramsey show
how are you doing
we're doing wonderful how can we help
today
yeah so
a few months ago I was in a traumatic
car accident
um I I work in the health care field and
I was a pedestrian going across the
street and I was hit by a car oh my gosh
so what happened so I have a
huh what happened
so I have um I have a lot of injuries I
have a brain injury
um a tibial Plateau fracture in my knee
my nose had to be realigned and
um
oh my I have a lot of scars on my face
and things like that and so I'm so sorry
I'm on I'm on workman's comp right now
um and I'm and I'm on light duty
um oh this happened while you were at
the hospital
on my way to work yes oh my goodness
okay all right and how how severe is the
TBI
what's that how severe is your brain
injury
um it's not it's not terrible
um my biggest uh problem is being able
to track
um like up and down and also to retain
um when I read something sometimes I
can't remember what I read the short
term memory okay yeah so I don't have
like dizziness and stuff like that but I
do have a lot of that effect and I
didn't like nothing affected
um just you know like I can still move
sure all my arms and all that stuff sure
I'm so sorry so how can we help today
well um I've been following you uh you
guys for quite a while and
um unlike most of I think most of your
followers I paid cash for my house about
20 years ago wow but I have a I have a
car payment and I have the money there
Judy why do you have a car payment I
have a car payment
because
well when I got hit I was in the process
of trying to get it paid off like I was
picking up extra shifts and things like
that and so what's left on the car
so 12 000 and then I have 70 000 in in
savings but I have a fear of because I'm
on work comp that you know I don't know
for sure if I'm going to be able to
return to my old job and things like
that
are you clear to drive
yeah okay I just want to make sure you
weren't paying on a depreciating asset
that's just Frozen in your driveway
right now is there any other financial
implications of your accident was there
a settlement insurance check anything
like that
none that has not happened yet I do have
an attorney for both uh pi and for the
work comp okay do you have any
disability insurance
um there will be eventually but I'm not
at MMI yet
okay
I I I'm still paying off this car
probably would pay it off too because it
frees up the payment and that 12 Grand
swing wasn't going to be the thing that
saved you anyways
if you couldn't get back to your other
life but what will take the stress off
is not having any payments that's your
only debt
yeah I like the idea of having a and I'm
thinking about this purely for the
mental stress
having no rent no car payment and at
least when it comes to nobody's gonna be
knocking on your door depending on what
happens next except for the tax tax man
right so it still leaves you with 58
Grand in savings and not a payment in
the world other than your normal bills
okay is your salary uh the same as it
was even though you're only on light
duty
yeah I didn't get it the only difference
is I was working nights and I was
getting
I was getting anywhere between
[Applause]
um 250 and 375 extra but because it we
were doing crisis pay
um at the time of the accident I was
getting about 23 extra per hour so okay
that some of that should be or all of
that should be considered as part of the
final set of settlement because the idea
of a settlement is we're going to make
you whole and right hold Judy worked
crisis shifts at night and made jillions
of dollars
um Judy now who's uh got a an iron knee
and a brand new beautiful nose
um is not able to work those shifts
right so we're that that's that's the
point of the settlement is to help make
Judy whole and so
um I would begin
I don't want to say anything negative
about anybody but if I'm not mistaken my
guess is people have been really really
really nice to you very kind and very
accommodating and very friendly and
I don't want that to Cloud your ability
to say okay here's what's gonna my
life's gonna be like in the next five
years ten years 20 years let's go ahead
and have some of these uncomfortable
hard conversations now
um or as soon as we get medical
clearance for the doctors say this is
about as good as this is going to get or
this is going to be the way this is for
the next five to ten years
um it can be hard to engage in those
conversations after your co-workers have
been so kind but if there's some fault
there man we need to go ahead and and
have those conversations sooner rather
than later well I I don't think you're
gonna regret paying off that car today
I'm heartbroken for you and the best
thing you can do is just try to get
better and get back to what you were
doing and I cannot imagine going through
a traumatic accident like that
and George I can tell you that
one of the things that makes us bananas
with anxiety is when you get literally
hit by a car walking on your way to work
right the last thing in the world you
would think would happen
um that little what if voice gets really
loud what if this happens what if this
happens what if this happens and for
those of us who haven't experienced that
kind of trauma it's easy to say it's not
going to happen she can't say that
anymore because for her it did happen so
when her body is sounding those alarms
those alarms are real and they are
sounding for a reason
you then have to
um say okay yeah that could happen I
could pay this car off and all of a
sudden all these crazy things happen I
only have 58 000 left and to make do
with the rest of my life that could
happen
but it probably won't and it's but the
probably won't that sentence gave me
more peace and I've seen it give people
peace like yeah you're right we could
get hit by him either right you're right
we could all just be trading Bitcoin and
we're all we all missed it we all missed
it but probably not well those are two
volume knobs and we tend to turn the
other one real loud right real I like
that I mean have you seen the news John
everything's imploded the stock market's
gonna go down to zero or probably not
probably not probably well it's a nice
reminder that we have control over those
dials and it's not easy yeah it's easy
to say oh just just turn that off John
it's not that hard it's it's wired into
it it's a daily Choice sometimes a
choice you make by the minute and by the
hour but it's worth doing for your own
sanity yeah in your own peace
financially mentally relationally thank
you Judy thanks for the thanks for
calling cheering you on your recovery
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney our scripture of the day
Ecclesiastes 3 1. there's an opportune
time to do things a right time for
everything on the Earth
the great Robin Williams once said
change is not popular we are creatures
of habit as human beings I want it to be
the way it was but if you continue the
way it was there will be no is
now that's one to chew on right there
John
very poetic
you'll get it tonight around 11 pm my
the gears are stuck
that's classic John hey that's what two
phds gets you all right let's go to the
phones triple eight eight two five five
two two five Serena joins us in Salt
Lake City Serena welcome to the show
hi thanks for having me sure how can we
help today
uh yeah so my workplace wants to set me
up with a credit card for travel and
events and I don't want to take it
because I've never had one so wondering
what do I do instead because I'm in baby
step three do they want you to apply for
one and get one or do they want you to
just give you a company card
I think it's a fly for one because it's
like technically through American
Express
but it's a business card that's through
the company but it has your name on it
is that the idea yeah it has my name on
it it would go on my credit score which
I don't care about and
it would I would have to just basically
take receipts and they would pay on the
credit I guess okay how often are you
traveling for work
uh twice a year and that's what the card
is for are there other expenses that are
more regular not just for like flights
and hotels and stuff and like during the
event when I need to get food
well couldn't they just book that for
you ahead of time are you traveling with
other people
basically I could use my own money and
they would reimburse me
so you can use your own money
yeah but since I'm in baby step three
I'm hesitant to
I usually don't have the funds to cover
how much that would cost yeah if you're
talking hey when it's 700 bucks for this
work trip you're like I don't really I
don't have the funds to cover that so
just just to give you an insight into
like when George and I travel
um I'm just and I'm doing this not to
kick you while you're down I want to
give you and Business Leaders listening
to this another alternative
George and I are gonna go be on an event
um we're going we're going to catch a
flight next week
the company will book the flight
the company will book The the rental car
and then on our desk will be an envelope
with cash in it that we're responsible
for and I've had to I've lost a receipt
on the road or I tip somebody a lot and
I and I've got to cover that cash but
I'm responsible for what cash is there
but the cash just is sitting on an
envelope on our desk
and
the idea here's the deal you're using
your money either way this is your
credit card and your credit and it's
your your butts on the line here and if
your company decides to not pay you back
it's this you're gonna owe that credit
card company the same as if you just use
your own debit card and pay your own
money I hate that for you that they put
you in this position that's not your job
to quote unquote reimburse
um what would they say if you just went
to them and say hey I don't do credit
cards I'm not comfortable opening one
um is there a business debit card you
could open for me or can you book it all
and give me petty cash for the road
basically they gave me a weird look like
why would I do a credit card
but I did talk to my manager and once I
explained to them how I've never had one
he was he understood that then that it
was more like a value Choice than just
simply me being difficult yeah and uh
but I don't I have a feeling that their
response was basically okay you'll have
to use your own money and then we'll
just reimburse you so I have a feeling
that would be different when's your next
trip here
June okay how long are you going to be
in baby step three four
uh probably for a few more months okay
would they give you cash ahead of time
if you said hey here's what this is
going to cost can you give me the cash
ahead of time I'll deposit it and I'll
pay for it
could that work I could ask it's an
option I just think there's always more
than one option and so if they're just
like well this is the only way there's a
lot of ways and people think we're crazy
because we there's literally not a
credit card in this company we Dave only
has a business debit card we have a
business debit card we use petty cash on
the road and it's it works every time
one of one of my favorite lines of
Dave's uh old Dave is when people used
to say I can't believe you would ever
give your employees a debit card with
access to some of your company's
checking accounts
and he said he would always respond I
can't believe you would hire somebody
that you don't like to carry your
business to customers with your name on
it that you don't even trust with a
couple of grand out of a checking
account like how would you hire somebody
that you wouldn't trust that way and so
I I I I don't know I I just hate that
Serena's business has put her in this
position you pay for everything we'll
cover you that's not your job and that's
the business's job if you're doing
business travel and if you travel with a
co-worker a leader and they want to put
it on their cars and start getting
reimbursed they can have more rewards
good for them and you won't have to deal
with this so I would just look at every
single option possible to get around
this stupidity appreciate the call all
right let's go to Jeremy in Louisiana
Jeremy welcome to the show
hey how are y'all we're doing great man
what's going on
to know uh I'm about 31 725 in total
debt not that you're counting down just
about it
should I sell my 2013 Toyota Tundra with
a 22.99 interest rate oh my gosh I know
I know which we can pay off in the next
four months uh after we get our tax
return we're getting about 2 500 back
I've only got 3 600 left on it what's it
worth
it's anywhere between you know 12 and 15
we're thinking
and then once you if you sold that you
would net about 10 grand
well I would probably do a private bill
I'd probably get everything and like you
said actually yeah like you said so
maybe 11 Grand Max and then we have to
turn around and get another car right
no my wife has a car and I also work for
an insurance company so I have a company
truck oh that I can actually drive
around as well so you don't even need to
see the mileage you know
really I don't
um because after we paid off the truck
we would we have about 4 600 on my car
we've got some other credit cards and a
bank loan I mean the most of the debt is
my student loan which is twenty thousand
eight hundred twenty five dollars what's
your household income
uh per month we make forty four hundred
dollars a month okay so if we sold this
car how how much does it speed up our
debt snowball
uh pretty much it takes out every debt
but my student loan I'm taking that deal
you're freeing up all those payments you
didn't need the truck in the first place
and if you want another truck down the
road we're going to do it we're going to
do it with cash instead of at 23
interest good gracious
what do you do for a living
so I was at the time when I bought the
truck I was a paramedics and I just I
just graduated paramedic school so I
said I need a truck and I bought that
stupid truck uh but right now I'm I'm a
claims adjuster for an insurance company
so you are smart enough to know blood
types how to stick needles in people how
to like shock them back to life had a
CPR yeah and then you sell that 22 and
you're like this is a great idea that's
a deal it's a great idea it's a great
idea did the salesman have a straight
face when they showed you that it's 23
interest like what would how do you even
deliver that very good
it's like this is the best thing for
y'all I bet he was like I've seen people
who have higher interest rates than you
man you're getting a deal
did you just have terrible credit yeah
your credit must have been about as good
as old dog poo like how bad was your
credit
my credit with the time I think was
about 650 and my wife had to co-sign but
she had a repossession on her oh God
Almighty Jeremy that's a terrible rate
I'm so glad you're listen uh here's what
we're gonna do as you're because you're
gonna sell this car by the end of this
weekend is you're going to be free I'm
gonna send you every dollar app for free
for a year and the new FPU lessons
because here's the deal you all need to
watch him again y'all are kicking butt
taking names but y'all need to watch
them again you're one bad day away from
another 23 car allowance dude yes so
hang on the line here and Austin's gonna
hook you up with FPU y'all watch these
videos together remind yourself why
you're doing this and for God Almighty
get rid of that truck I'd walk back into
that car dealership and and have some
words once that thing's paid up not even
go back in there again just a thank you
letter for teaching me uh something
about life thank you letter that puts
this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books my thanks to Dr John deloney all
the guys in the booth and you America
until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
kundaloni if you like what you heard in
this episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramsaysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]